[Music]
on this friday night
canada on another troubling trajectory
the fear of a rapid rise in cases with
deadlier variants
starting to dominate we are in a very
tight race
between vaccines versus variants and
canada's vaccine delivery is hit with
another delay
hatred against women who are black and
muslim it has definitely been a
horrifying and traumatizing experience
the rise of vicious assaults in alberta
the suez crisis
a stuck ship could set gas prices
soaring
plus don't give up marking emancipation
day
i think it's a start remembering a
shameful part of canadian history
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
with new insight tonight into where
canada stands in the race between
vaccines and variants
and it isn't looking good over the last
two weeks daily cases have jumped by
more than 30 percent
and with highly contagious variants in
the mix canada is at risk of a dangerous
surge
new federal modeling shows if we
maintain our current rate of social
contacts
canada could see 12 000 cases per day
in the next few weeks public health
officials say we could prevent that
if we reduce who we see new data out of
ontario is fueling concerns about the
new variants
a group of experts has found the risk of
hospitalization
and death is much higher than the
original version of the virus
michael couture has tonight's top story
on the warnings
and what must be done to avoid a rapid
rise of new cases
first of all a message to the people of
ontario do not light your guard down
despite that warning ontario's premiere
is relaxing restrictions in certain
areas for
certain activities next month nail and
hair salons will be allowed to reopen in
the province's gray level lockdown zone
and outdoor gym training is being
permitted
we should all be on high alert uh
absolutely high alert
but you know i got to be frank p people
are tired
i'm telling you they're tired they're
exhausted out there that may be true but
canada's chief public health officer
is anxious with passover easter and
ramadan
approaching and covet 19 variants
spreading
dr teresa tam fears a repeat of
christmas
where people got together ignoring
health guidelines
we are in a very tight race between
vaccines
versus variants new soon to be released
data
shows just how dangerous those variants
are
according to ontario's science advisory
table covid19 variants result
in an approximately 60 percent increase
risk of hospitalization
and a similar increase in risk of death
as compared
to the original strain we have two
pandemics we have the pandemic with the
with the early variants completely under
control contained
and the pandemic with the new variants
absolutely out of control and that's
what we need to address now and they
need to address it especially with
younger adults
according to new federal modeling
infection rates among people 80
and older have dropped dramatically
since january which coincides with the
ramp up in vaccinations
the bigger concern now is that the
highest number of cases is being
reported
in younger adults aged 20 to 39.
it's why canada's chief public health
officer is asking people to hold on
until the fall
when perhaps things can be a little more
normal
you're going to be able to go back into
your social spaces schools
universities in a way that you can
manage
and not have to keep shut things down
but dr tam stressed it will all be based
on the data and not
a specific date adding personal
protective measures will likely remain
in place
for some time robin mike look at her in
ottawa thanks mike
there is some temporary trouble with a
vaccine shipment
the federal government had been
expecting a delivery of 590
000 doses of the moderna vaccine this
weekend
but it's been delayed until next week
because of a backlog in the company's
quality assurance process
come next week canada should get a big
bump in vaccine deliveries
in addition to the 590 000 delayed
modernity doses
canada is expecting nearly 1.2 million
pfizer biontech doses
plus 1.5 million astrazeneca doses from
the u.s
the government says those will be
arriving by truck on tuesday
so add it all up in total canada will
get 3.2
million doses
we are now seeing that supply surge
and it is set to continue during the
next
three weeks canada is scheduled to
receive the same number of doses
that we have received over the course of
the last
three months and this schedule will
continue
to accelerate in canada today
almost 217 000 doses have been given out
more than 4.1 million canadians have now
received at least one dose
that works out to nearly 11 percent of
the population
now to a disturbing murder investigation
unfolding in ontario
a doctor has been charged with
first-degree murder and police say
they're investigating a number of
suspicious deaths
at the hospital where he works the
deaths happened at the general hospital
in hawkesbury
a town between ottawa and montreal
police say they made an arrest at the
hospital last night they did not name
the suspect
but he's been identified as dr brian
nadler his lawyer says he maintains his
innocence and will vigorously
defend himself a former canadian soldier
has pleaded guilty in a sexual assault
case that led to an independent
investigation into sexual misconduct
in the military in 2011 andre gagnon
assaulted stephanie ramon
after a party at an armory near quebec
city he was tried by court martial and
acquitted in 2014.
eventually the case went to the supreme
court of canada and a new trial was
ordered
in 2013 riemann spoke to mclean's
magazine about the assault and her
negative experience reporting it
the coverage led to the military
establishing operation
honor an effort to stamp out sexual
misconduct in the military
this week the military announced the end
of operation honor
the decision came after many victims
said they felt it was ineffective
and poisoned a series of racially
motivated attacks against black muslim
women in alberta has the province on
edge
at least seven women have been targeted
in edmonton and calgary since december
in the most recent incident a teenage
girl was threatened and physically
assaulted
the muslim community says islamophobia
and anti-black racism
have always been a problem in the
province but the pandemic has made it
worse
heather york's west explains muslim
women in alberta
are exhausted it has definitely been a
horrifying and traumatizing experience
for the muslim community at large
in recent months black muslim women
wearing hijab in edmonton and calgary
have been targets in a series of racist
attacks
in december a mother and daughter were
violently assaulted in an edmonton mall
parking lot
less than a week later another woman was
attacked at a city transit station
and just last weekend a 28-year-old
woman was charged after a racially
motivated assault on a teenage girl
police say the woman yelled racist slurs
kicked and punched the girl
and removed her hijab these seven
attacks on muslim woman
showcase how large of an issue it is the
national council of canadian muslims has
been calling on local government leaders
to take
action edmonton's mayor says the city
has improved security around
transit stations but he also believes
there is a larger problem
at play with you know the the tiki
torches that we saw here in edmonton
as part of the anti-mask rally last
month
you know i think there is a needed
conversation
about ensuring that symbols of hate
are are properly recognized
[Applause]
for months calgary and edmonton have
seen weekly protests against
coveted restrictions along with the use
of tiki torches the rallies have also
seen the presence of known
white nationalist groups like the proud
boys the freedom rallies are not freedom
rallies you can call them whatever you
want to call it a smurf parade i don't
care
it is not that it's a hate rally
edmonton's police chief has denounced
the use of tiki torches at the rallies
but he says there's little legally that
can be done calgary police say
no formal complaints have been made and
so
the rallies continue as muslim women
continue
feeling unsafe heather eurix west global
news
calgary the ever given is causing
ever-growing chaos in the suez canal it
is now going on
four days since the massive container
ship became stuck
cutting off one of the world's most
important shipping routes
so far efforts to free the ship have
failed and as eric sorensen reports
the toll is growing by the day
it is still stuck but now heavy dredging
equipment has been moved in to try to
free the giant vessel
ever given and unplug the suez canal
engineers and salvage experts are
puzzling over how to do it
the company that owns the ship has
apologized officials suggest a wind and
dust storm may have caused it to run
aground
one maritime expert thinks speed may
have been a factor for a vessel that is
almost
a half kilometer long it went a little
too fast
but when you were a little too fast and
you made a little
error it's hard to correct it
global trade is being slowed oil prices
have risen perishable foods could be
lost
an astounding 12 percent of global trade
passes through the canal
dozens of ships some carrying thousands
of containers now sit idle
satellite images show the number of
ships standing by is growing
the impact on canada wouldn't be
immediate but will be felt
because we're in a global world things
like that
have uh have impact so you know
a price increase in europe more backlog
in europe
clearly something that is impacting here
as well
the suez was one of the world's
engineering marvels when it was
constructed in the 19th century
it has been deepened and widened over
the decades as global trade has come to
depend on it even more
shipping from the mediterranean south
and from the red sea northward
transports an estimated 12 billion
dollars worth of goods through the canal
each day some companies are detouring
already
if it were choked off for long more will
consider shipping around south africa
turning a two-week trip into four to six
weeks for some vessels
she's jammed in there pretty good and so
it's going to be very difficult
to pull her off there is of course
something comical about a giant ship
getting stuck
sideways and it's launched a million
memes illustrating the woes we feel when
a problem's too big
admiring the spirit of two guys in a
teensy bulldozer
someone proposed a little canadian
know-how or a dose of austin powers
ingenuity
but the crisis is getting more serious
the longer it takes to dislodge a 200
000 ton
ship that's causing one of the most
expensive traffic jams in history
eric sorensen global news toronto
new rules in an american battleground
coming up why it will be tougher for
people in georgia to vote
plus violent collision the chaos moments
after a train crash
and the surprise sight over the west
coast
[Music]
hero they're terrifying and chaotic
moments after a deadly train crash in
egypt
passengers inside a mangled train car
scrambled to free themselves
at least 30 people were killed when two
trains collided
more than a hundred others were injured
with dozens taken to hospital
rail authorities say the emergency
brakes were activated
suddenly causing one train to smash into
the back of the other
at least two passenger cars flipped over
egypt's prime minister says
any error or negligence will not be
tolerated
and the perpetrator will be held
accountable
at least 10 people have been killed in a
fire that consumed a hospital in mumbai
the private facility was caring for
patients with copin 19.
more than 70 patients had to be
transferred to other hospitals
india has detected what it believes is a
double mutation of the virus and that's
led to a troubling surge in cases
in the past 24 hours mumbai has seen a
record rise
more than 5 500 cases
nearly five months after donald trump
lost his bid for reelection
republicans are working overtime to
suppress voter rights
in the state of georgia there are tough
new measures that will make it much
harder for supporters of democrats and
minorities
to cast a ballot jackson prosco explains
a knock on the governor's door landed a
georgia lawmaker in handcuffs
hauled out of the state house he's not
under arrest for attempting to watch
governor brian kemp
sign restrictive new voting measures
into law after the november election
last year i knew
like so many of you that significant
reforms to our state elections were
needed
in georgia it's now a crime to offer
food or water to anyone waiting to vote
in predominantly black counties the
lines can stretch for hours
there are also tougher id requirements
for mail in voting
and limits on the hours for ballot drop
boxes you know we won georgia just so
you understand
donald trump's big lie about a stolen
election was never true
but it gave republicans an opening to
crack down they are using
the lie about voter fraud as a pretext
for voter suppression and it's not just
georgia
republicans in 43 states have proposed
hundreds of bills to make it harder to
vote
democrats say urban and black voters are
the primary targets
in moves that hearken back to the era of
jim crow and segregation
this is nothing but punitive designed to
keep people from voting
you can't provide water for people
about to vote give may not break for
republicans there's another factor
it's getting harder to win once
conservative strongholds like georgia
texas and arizona are moving to the left
there's
nothing else supporting this legislation
then reducing the size of the democratic
electorate
through hook and crook and maximizing
the white vote that still votes
republican the laws are all but
certain to face court challenges they've
led president biden to call for passage
of a national voting rights act to
combat suppression
without one there are fears the next
election may be decided
not by who votes but by who can't
jackson prosko global news washington
still ahead a different kind of currency
exchange how bitcoin technology is
tackling
climate change
what is that
well this site had star gazers across
the west coast
stumped from bc to oregon witnesses
wondered if the light show was a meteor
shower a satellite or even a ufo
the u.s national weather service says it
was likely debris from a spacex falcon 9
rocket
that recently sent a batch of starlink
satellites into orbit
over the past year bitcoin's value has
increased more than eight-fold
and critics say how howit's mind using
powerful computers
is leaving a huge carbon footprint but
as redmond shannon explains
the technology that underpins the
currency called blockchain
has the potential to tackle climate
change
the 2015 paris climate agreement
optimistically laid out
global goals for tackling emissions the
ongoing
issue is that nations can't agree how
those goals will be met
one booming emission source since paris
is cryptocurrency mining
currently estimated to use as much
energy worldwide
as all of sweden the bitcoin mining
company bit farms has
five locations in quebec where it uses
only
renewable energy we know the world is
evolving
very quickly to having to
deal with carbon credits and carbon
offsets and and
really heading for a net zero type of
approach so we're very mindful of that
worldwide most cryptocurrency miners are
not
using renewable energy but the
technology behind bitcoin
called blockchain could also help in
tackling climate change
blockchain is a form of database where
transaction data
is securely held across a network pedro
buys is the head of research at the
blockchain and
climate institute a think tank set up to
help governments and
organizations harness the green power of
blockchain
when we look at the financial sector as
a whole and
of the green or sustainable financial
products by far
green bonds stand out from the crowd it
could be one of those financial
instruments that really helps to
mobilize the
trillions of dollars that we need to
tackle to help tackle climate change
bis says blockchain combined with
satellite monitoring of
carbon offset projects could make green
bonds
far more economic secure and transparent
the nature of the system could force
governments to honor their commitments
in a carbon trading scheme really what
we need is not just these
tax or or or labels of great what we
need is impact
what we need is measurable action that
we say oh yeah we remove this amount of
co2
we remove these amounts of you know
energy consumption blockchain's full
potential on climate could be unlocked
at the cop26 summit
this fall if leaders strike a deal
on carbon trading rules redmond shannon
global news
london tomorrow on the new reality
redmond delves into how blockchain
technology could shape our future from
real estate
to elections be sure to tune in at 7 p.m
up next remembering the writer behind
beezus and ramona
one of the world's most beloved
children's authors has died
beverly cleary became a household name
with her books about the rambunctious
ramona quimby
her first work was published in 1950.
since then her books have sold more than
85
million copies and have been translated
into 29 different languages
according to publisher collins cleary
died yesterday in california
she was 104 years old i remember her
book so well
so often we forget canada's history of
slavery but the truth is
it happened in this country now members
of parliament have officially designated
august 1st as emancipation day it was on
that day in 1834
that britain abolished slavery across
the british empire
as ross lord reports descendants of
slaves hope
there is real change when it comes to
the racism they still face today
some parts of the world like caribbean
countries already celebrate
emancipation day so do some canadian
cities like toronto
[Music]
but with parliament making august first
emancipation day throughout canada
there are high hopes it will become more
than just a political gesture
i think it's a start towards an official
recognition that slavery actually
was practiced here in canada it takes
some digging to uncover
in this 1807 document 27 loyalist
slaveholders
pressure the nova scotia house of
assembly to let them continue holding
their 88 slaves
saying property in negros was maintained
and acknowledged if not encouraged
by the british government the
petitioners called on the government to
secure their property by law
or compensate them if slavery was
abolished
slavery was outlawed across the british
empire by 1834
31 years before the united states
followed suit
but descendants of slaves those who
either escaped to canada through the
famed underground railroad
or were enslaved here say that legacy
endures
that early history is still underpinning
what we're dealing with today
in addressing issues of anti-black
racism
senator wanda thomas bernard of nova
scotia fought to have emancipation day
recognized nationally she says black
canadians have been forced to rely on
oral tradition rather than documented
history maybe her descendants will have
a head start
i don't want them to have to put their
family history together
like a jigsaw puzzle no child in canada
should have to do that
the movement to establish emancipation
day was 25 years in the making
activists hope it won't take another 25
years for the government to formally
recognize
and apologize for slavery and its
continuing impact
to bring about all the systemic changes
that are required
to make canada what canada professes to
be a free and open country
for everyone ross lord global news
halifax and that is global national for
this friday i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is snowy calgary
thanks for watching have a great night